i'm curious since we're going to the
rich poor conversation what would you
say are the top three to five rules on
money
if you could boil it down to three to
five it's a game the number one rule is
it's a game you're playing a game it's
that simple if you look at it as a game
just like anything you can get better at
it right like i don't know whatever game
you play if you play uno if you play
monopoly if you play clue if you play
manga if you play fortnite if anything
you play
you know you're going to get good i
remember in my time i was playing
fester's quest i played zelda but it was
also what was the mario kart as a super
mario kart and you know how you would do
the three jumps and then bam it's going
fast and i would beat this time 32
seconds i was so proud of it but i
played it 50 000 times right so the game
with money
it's it's exactly what it is once you
learn how to play the game with money
then it has to do with timing then it
has to do with different kind of things
like you know a a year ago i get a call
from a guy who needs cash it's okay
so
he needs an investment he he has
something he has to sell immediately to
get cash in return okay because he needs
the money right away so it's okay so uh
what are you selling he says it's the
two greatest wayne gretzky cards and a
top sold in 2016 for 205 000
so two cards combined sold in 2016 for
600 and i said okay what do you want to
sell it for he's like 600 000. yeah of
course he wants to
so i'm not going to pay you that i mean
you know he wants 650 so i'm not going
to pay that but we talked about it and
eventually gave me a number right
and it was still a number i had to still
cough up you know half a million dollar
check to the guy so i like greatness i
like anybody that just goes and crushes
it with their game right so i buy this
card so i buy the card i don't think
much of it one card not two two cards
both of them i bought both of them yeah
wow so the other guy who owns the card
wouldn't sell his card for a million
dollars if you paid it to him so here's
what i do now two guys own the card me
and the other guy there's only two of us
okay
you paid a million he won't sell it to
you so that means there's only one in
the market because it's me because i'm
willing to sell it right yeah so it's on
ebay right if you go on ebay right now
you type in gretzky opt it's on market
right now for a million dollars right
wow one of them is on the market four
million the other one's on the market
for 400 000. so you asked me for rule of
money i had cash
if i don't have cash like that i can't
double my money that quickly so we just
talk about three of them money's a game
you need cash because opportunity is
going to come up and it's a doubles game
so if i put this game it's a doubles
game everything about money is a doubles
game what's that mean the doubles game
to me is i pay you a thousand dollars
can we double it in six months
no how long in 12 months okay no problem
i'll do a double in a year here's a
thousand dollars i get a double bag
right so if you take a thousand and you
double it every year what happens
thousand goes into two four eight
sixteen thirty two sixty four two fifty
six five two of a million
a thousand dollars is nine doubles away
from a million wow now you take a
million and see what happens if we
double it nine times one million goes
into two million four million eight
million sixteen million thirty two sixty
four one twenty eight two fifty six five
two of a billion a million is ten
doubles away from a billion how do you
find the doubles well that's the game
that's the part of the game that's what
i'm trying to tell you so so the doubles
now becomes investment opportunities you
know what you buy into do you start a
company where has a high value you know
you can really scale it and finding
something that can scale do you invest
into things that are gonna give you six
eight ten percent or you're going to go
play ball and take the risk that's the
game so you got to find those and
they're out there by the way yeah yep
they're out there warren buffett's a
doubles game all these guys are a
doubles game and
is investing in businesses yes i'm a
business guy i'm not a real estate guy
there are people that are by the way
that doesn't mean real estate doesn't
work i mean it wouldn't make any sense
for me to say there's real estate
billionaires everywhere our president is
a real estate billionaire so for me to
knock real estate would would have no
value to it but for me i'm more about i
have an idea what are you guys doing me
and tiffany are thinking about starting
a
a marketing company okay how can this
thing scale well let me tell you what we
got we got three packages boom boom boom
we're going to be target audience we're
going to be targeting people in this
world okay interesting how much are
going to be we foresee us doing six
million dollars in revenue within 24
months and i'll tell you one more would
be
you have to be maniacally
maniacal about being patient
i mean you have to be patiently
aggressive you know patiently aggressive
it's so
tough to do
because you want your money to double
now exactly it might take 10 years yeah
but but if you are willing to do the 10
years it may double 40 times
it may double 30 times
you know like when bezos said just hang
tight i'm not going to give you
dividends just trust me on this trust me
on this right
and at the beginning if you've heard the
story where he goes and raises two
million dollars fifty thousand dollars
from forty people that's what two
million dollars and he gives them twenty
percent
wow
twenty percent about twenty percent
gives them twenty percent just for two
million dollars you know what that 20 is
worth today
200 billion dollars that's the point so
can you imagine 1994 amazon gets started
forget about you put 2 million just say
you put 50 million just with you you put
50 000
what is a half a percent of a 2 of a
trillion company right now
a half a percent you're still a half a
billionaire wow your 50 000 is worth 500
million dollars give or take whatever
the numbers we're doing right the point
is
that is a massive victory the guy who
put ten thousand dollars and he gave it
to berkshire hathaway in 1974 i don't
know if you've heard this story you know
warren buffett is starting he says i'll
give you ten thousand dollars never
touches the money goes back to his
regular job makes a hundred grand a year
you know
have you read this article no tell me
the ten thousand dollars if you go on
business insider you pull it up is worth
780 today
780 million million never did anything
to it so that's the part about patiently
aggressive yeah it's very hard to do but
the doubles get bigger later on once you
once you're identifying that part then
it's figuring out your own talents that
you have
and once i know my talents where can my
talents be used you know if you're a
numbers guy what industry can use your
talents well maybe it's finance economy
investment banker you know maybe it's on
that side if it's a creative side maybe
i'm going to go
be on the marketing side maybe i want to
be behind the scenes i don't want to be
in front of camera i want to be the
support person
then you say well i'm not a good number
one guy i'm a good number two person i'm
a number three person then you have to
find out you're positioning at the po at
the point of your life tom was the
former president of our company php uh
one of the best decisions was hiring
this guy and i said so tom let me ask
you a question in your life you you guys
sold jam that for 780 million you got a
massive exit but you were the number six
guy
how come you don't want to be the number
one guy he says good question he gave me
the best answer he says you realize i'm
54 years old at the time we were talking
he says it took me 54 years to realize
i'm not a good number one
54 years 54 years to realize i'm not a
good number one what would have happened
if you realize that
at 30. that's the point every one of his
biggest checks he ever got he was the
number five the number four or the
number every time he was number one the
company didn't do well
so sometimes we want to be number one
but maybe you're not a number one
sometimes you want to be mj but maybe
you're scotty sometimes you want to be
mj and scotty but maybe you're john
paxton and steve kerr maybe you're
somebody that later on is going to be
the general manager of the you know
chicago bulls your name is uh john
paxton maybe you're going to be a great
coach years later winning three out of
five championships your name is steve
kerr but you got to play your game with
your strength
you may be a number six right now but
you may eventually be a good number one
maybe it's just a different role in a
different package
yes but it's the sequencing man
everything is sequencing what does
sequencing mean for you
sequencing to me means okay
you if you wake up every day you have a
sequence of what you do okay like what's
the first thing you do when you wake up
mostly meditate okay what's the next
thing you do make my bed and what's the
next thing you do brush my teeth shower
okay that's a sequence okay so that now
what if i wake up and the first thing i
do
is i shower first okay then i go eat
then i put my clothes on then i go to
work and i say sometime throughout the
day i'm gonna meditate i just messed the
whole sequence up
what is the foundation of what i'm
starting the day with right yeah what is
the sequence of what i'm going to be
doing next if every decision you're
about to make next whether it's marriage
having kids business partnership a joint
venture if everything you did you
stepped away from the world your girl
your mom your dad your peers your family
you went to a restaurant you sat there
with a piece of paper saying okay i'm
thinking about marriage what do i need
to do next
what's the next move i need to make then
you go i don't know if that's number one
i think that's number three and you play
that game it's fascinating
it's fascinating it's like playing chess
it's like you know these master chess
players they know their next 10 to 50
moves the amateurs were like
uh
here we go this is what i'm going to do
you know these guys are like
what are you doing yeah they see it in
the future sequencing